You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Speaking of Psychology is taking a summer break, so we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past. In November, I talked to psychologist Michael Yeomens and journalist Charles Duhigg about what makes for great conversations and how anyone can learn to communicate better.
We hope you enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of Psychology, we'll be back with new episodes in late August. Thank you for listening. You probably know what it feels like when a conversation. just clicks. You and the person you're talking to understand each other. They're not just listening to you, they're hearing what you're saying. You leave the conversation feeling good. Maybe you sparked a new friendship or deepened an old one or figured out how to solve a problem that's been bothering you. Conversational chemistry might seem intangible, something that just happens when the circumstances are right.
But psychologists using new research tools and methods are beginning to figure out. out what makes some conversations work while others fall flat. And their insights can help people improve their conversation skills, strengthen their relationships, and even disagree in more productive ways. So what makes conversations click? Why are some people so much better at verbal communication than others? What role does listening play in conversation and how can you learn to listen better? Why is it important to think about your goals in a conversation and to consider your partner conversation goals as well. What's the best way to build rapport with someone you just met? How can you disagree productively without having the conversation spiral into an argument?
And what are the most important things you can do to improve your conversation skills? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. I have two guests today. First is Dr. Michael Yeomens, an assistant professor of strategy and organizational behavior at Imperial College in London. Dr. Yomans has a PhD in behavioral science from the University of Chicago Booth School of Business and was previously a postdoctoral fellow at the Harvard Business School.
His research uses an artificial intelligence method called natural language processing to analyze conversations, to understand and improve, how people communicate with one another. He's interested in how people make decisions and conversations and how we can make those decisions better. Next is Charles Duhigg, a Pulitzer Prize-winning journalist and author. His new book to be published in February 2024
is called Super Communicators, How to Unlock the Secret Language of Connection, and it's all about the science of conversation. Mr. Duhigg has written for The New Yorker magazine and The New York Times, among other publications. He is also the author of Two Beaux best-selling books, the power of habit about habit formation, and smarter, faster, better, about the science of productivity.
Thank you both for joining me today. Thanks for having us. Thanks, Kim. It's a pleasure to be here. We've all met people who seem to be naturally great at conversation. They can connect with anyone. Charles, in your book, you call people like the super communicators. So why don't we start there?
Who are these super communicators? And do you have any really great examples? Yeah, well, I think actually all of us know super communicators. And oftentimes we are super communicators ourselves. If I was to ask, I'm everyone listening to think of the person that you would call if you were having a bad day, the person you know that would make you just feel better, kind of listen to you exactly the right way. Everyone listening would have someone pop into their mind. And that person for you is a super communicator. They know how to listen. They know how to show their listening. They know how to speak in ways that it's easier for you. you to listen. And we all have these moments in our own lives when we when we know exactly the right thing to say to a friend to make them feel better. Or we know exactly what to say during a
meeting in order to get everyone on board with our idea. It's not a magical power is the thing. It's a set of skills that some people have learned a little bit better that recognize more. But there's skills that all of us can learn, instincts that all of us have that if we're reminded how to use them, we can communicate with anyone. Now, Mike, you don't use that term in your work, the term super communicators, but do you come across people like this in your studies? And what are they doing that the rest of us aren't? Yeah, Kim, I think it's a great term. I come across some of my studies.
And if I'm lucky, I come across a few in my life every once in a while, too. I think Charles describes it really aptly, right? These are people who understand their conversation partner. They understand the goals they want to achieve and what their partner. wants to achieve and have the skills, have the adeptness, the quickness and the sensitivity to be able to build a conversation from turn to turn over time so that it actually adds up to something much bigger than that, right? Not just exchanging words, but meeting of minds. And I think Charles also makes a really good point about the nature of the relationship, right? Like so often
when we are at our conversational best, it's because we're with people we understand well, we know, other patterns, we know what they're looking for, we maybe share a sense of humor with them. And there's a bit of a filtering at who we end up talking to, right? We tend to seek out the people we've had good experiences with before. But I think we can learn from those situations the kinds of skills and tools that can be useful more broadly. And a lot of what the real super communicators do, the people who are good like this with everybody, is that they understand how to adapt their toolkit to the needs in the context in front of them. One thread that runs through the work that both of you do is the importance of understanding
that there are many different kinds of conversations than conversational goals. Why is it important to understand your own goals and your partner's goals in conversation? Well, in many ways, a conversation is all about the goals, right? We oftentimes enter into a conversation with a specific objective in mind, although we might not be aware of that objective ourselves. And one of the things that I've really loved about doing this research, including Mike's research and many of his colleagues, is that as we learn more about how communication works within our minds, we've learned that there are different kinds of conversations, right? And in particular, it seems like there's sort of three big buckets that we can put a lot of conversations into. There's conversations that are practical,
right? I want to decide where we're going to dinner tonight or what we should do about the fact that Jimmy can't get his homework in on time. Or I want to talk about, you know, what we should do as we get older. And that's kind of a conversation about, like, what are we really talking about? What do we want to figure out here? But then there's other types of conversations where the goal is not to come up with a plan or to use reason to figure things out. It's just to share with you how I feel. And those are emotional conversations where what we're talking about is how do I feel.
And then another big bucket are social conversation. discussions where I am sharing who I am from an identity perspective, from a background perspective, based on my experiences. I want to learn who you are based on where you come from and what you believe in. And that's really a social conversation, a conversation about who are we? And what's important is that a lot of the research shows if I come into a conversation and I'm talking about emotions, if I come home from work one day and I've had a tough day and I'm telling my wife all about my boss who's a jerk and my coworkers don't appreciate me, me and my wife responds with some very good practical advice. Like, why don't you take your boss to lunch and get to know him a little bit better? Even though she's trying to be supportive, even though that's very good advice, it's unlikely
I'm going to hear it. We've all been in this situation where I'm having an emotional conversation and she's having a practical conversation. And as a result, we don't connect. We don't hear each other. We both walk away a little bit frustrated. So I think one of the big things that I've carried away from reviewing this research is, it's important to have the same kind of conversation at the same time.
And that means understanding what your own goal is and what other people's goals are in a discussion. So, Mike, does that mean that people need to announce to each other what they want to talk about, what the purpose of the conversation is? Does that make you a better conversationalist? I think a little bit of announcing could be helpful. I also think a little bit of asking could be helpful too, right? there's many parties involved. I mean, we, I think those three categories are, it's a nice way of thinking about the
different types of conversations we might hope to achieve. And it's tricky because every conversation could be a mix of a few of them, right? And because every relationship you have is a series of conversations over time, right? So you need to be able to apply, you know when to apply the skills at the right time. You know, I think some people don't know their own goals. You know, they'll, you know, business scholars will do these studies where people write down their objectives for like, you know, the next year at work or the next five years of their life. And you'd be surprised how often people miss common objectives, even just describing their own goals. And I think the same is true of conversation, right?
Simply listing the goals you might have before a conversation to be clear of what those are, right? And maybe even thinking through some of the topics you might cover when you're talking with somebody. can only hope, I think, to help you achieve those goals merely by identifying them, but also doing a bit of cognitive offloading in the sense that rather than having to do the cognitive work of trying to think what you're trying to achieve as you're trying to achieve it, by just putting a little bit of preparation in advance, then the actual conversation will flow a lot smoother. And I think the same is also true about preparing to understand your partner. Now, you don't know exactly what their goals are yet either, but you can at least have a plan to learn what those goals are.
I think Mike brings up a really important point here, which is that oftentimes a conversation that we have is not just one conversation, right? We're not just talking about emotions or just talking about social topics. We move from conversation to conversation. And what's important is that our partner is able to recognize as we're moving from topic to topic and is inviting us. to join them in a certain kind of conversation. And one of the things that really strikes me is that when we are in those conversations, oftentimes we are announcing our goals, right? If we're trained to look for it, if someone is obviously emotional,
if someone is using emotional words, if someone is saying things like, this is how I feel or I was angry, then they're announcing like, I want to have an emotional conversation. Or if they're saying, look, we got to get down to business. So we've got to figure out what the budget is for next year. They're announcing that they want to have a practical conversation. And part of it is just training ourselves to listen for that. I'm wondering how you both got interested in this topic.
Charles, let's start with you because your profession, as a journalist, involves a particular type of communication. Can you be a good reporter without knowing some of the basics that you cover in your book and what Dr. Yolman studies? Well, it's, and I'm really interested to hear Mike's take, answer to this as well. One of the things that I found was happening to me was that I was really good at being an interviewer, right? I could ask questions. But an interview is not a conversation. A conversation is really when both people are participating, we're both hopefully being a little
bit vulnerable with each other and reciprocating some of that vulnerability. We're both in the conversation as opposed to one person interrogating the other, which is what an interview is often like. And I found that this was a real drawback at work. Like I was a great reporter, but when I was made a manager at the New York Times, I just discovered I was the worst communicator on earth. Like people would come to me with problems and I would try and solve them immediately because I thought that was my job and they would get upset because they're like, quit trying to solve my problem.
I just want you to understand how I feel. I was terrible at this. And so that's when I started thinking to myself, like, I actually need to understand how communication works because because we all we have evolved to communicate right it's it's our species like secret superpower and yet so often we're in conversations where we feel like we don't fully understand what the other person's trying to say and they haven't heard us and I think that part of the barrier there is just not understanding how communication works and so I wanted to learn more about it and Mike what about you what made you focus on this professionally I mean I think it's a
incredible topic for anyone to be studying now. In graduate school in Chicago, I really got excited about decision-making, right? How it is that people make choices to follow through on their best intentions. And very often that was studied in very simple domains in the sense that people say they want to retire for, say for retirement, they want to give more to charity, they want to save on energy usage. We're trying to come up with ways for people to align their behavior with those intentions. And those are relatively easy to measure. I think all the same kinds of mistakes and biases and juristics that plague our decision making in the uncertain world of finance or the
uncertain world of, you know, dieting and exercise, health more broadly maybe. I think all of those same problems are also applied to conversations. It's just hard to measure. It's hard to figure out because there's so many different kinds of goals and because the way we talk to one another is structured for humans by evolution, but not structured to be understood by computers. There was just a dart of real understanding of conversation and that kind of decision-making level. And so these days, I think with the advent of technology that's allowing us to, you know, for example, the technology that's recording this podcast right now and we'll give us a transcript after we're done, the ability of tools to capture conversation. but also to enable new kinds of conversations that we never used to have, whether it's with, you know, globally distributed work teams or text messaging, you know, with our oldest friends or, you know, networking apps that allow us to connect with people. We might never interact with otherwise, you know, people in online courses, that kind of thing. You know, the new, the ways in which we're recording those conversations and the new conversations that are being enabled by technology means that it seems like such a, it's just seems like such a lot of. a natural fit for the kinds of empirical tools that psychologists are used to applying to simple problems.
So, Mike, I know that you've done a lot of research around kind of turn taking in conversations and what it sounds like when a conversation is good that people are often interrupting each other and there's callbacks to previous things and they're asking questions. So a conversation like this, if you and I were sitting in a bar with Kim and we were talking as opposed to we're in three different cities and we're talking over over the computer. How do you think a conversation would be different? In person versus online.
And, you know, including alcohol in the mix, definitely would change the conversation too. Right, right, right. And probably some background noise and verbal or visual cues that were giving each other. Yeah, well, and hopefully a much more wide open range of topics. I think we have a lot of time to dig in deep into one another and pass the baton a little bit more. You know, I've certainly enjoyed getting to know you guys a little bit getting ready for this conversation, but I have so many follow-up questions.
I won't bore the audience with that. I want to ask a question about technology because, Mike, you just raised that. And, you know, we're hearing more and more that younger people. They don't use their phone, for example, for a conversation. They use it to text. and the kids, I'm using the term loosely, but I'm an old person. So younger people don't even want to have conversations. They'd much rather interact using technology.
What will that do to conversation as a skill? One question is whether it substitutes for normal face-to-face conversation that we're used to having or whether it's a compliment, right? In some ways, it could complement, right? Like, I text my friends and figure out when we're going to meet up, and then we meet up. And then we meet up and then we can call back to things we've talked about. We can reference jokes from our meeting and engage in responsive action based on plans we've made. All of that makes the connecting of conversations in a relationship much more powerful. But I think it was good research that others have done and probably know better showing that in some ways it's substituting for the more tangible relationships in our lives, right?
That social media is maybe not quite as social as we'd hope. So that's a tricky business. I don't know much of that research as well. Charles, do you? Well, a little bit. And I think one thing that it's important to remember is I think it's a really good question, right? Because it is such a new form of communication. I have a 12-year-old and a 15-year-old. And I don't know that they ever call their friends, but they're talking to their friends constantly. But the one caution I would offer is, you know, when telephones first emerged, there was a flurry of articles claiming that being able to be able to be. to communicate telephonically would destroy our ability to have conversations. Like all these people who don't have to go see each other in person now, they can just call
across the city to talk to each other. And of course, all of us have had conversations on the phone that we feel like are as intimate and as personal as any that we've had in real, in face to face. In other words, we kind of learn how to use a communication medium in the best way possible. And one of the things that's happening with online right now is. is that we're learning how to do it, right? Like, we've been talking to each other face-to-face for two millennia, and we've been talking on telephones for over 100 years.
But when it comes to, like, sending someone an emoji and, like, trying to figure out all the hidden meanings that I don't know exist about it, that's a relatively new phenomena. But we will learn, and we are learning how to do it. And I think what's important is that at the beginning stages, and there's a lot of really interesting research around this, around how why people come into conflict online and why they don't. And I think the general policy is if you over-emphasize what you know you're supposed to do,
like if you overemphasize being polite, if you overemphasize stating your intention, if you avoid things that are really subtle, like, like, you know, some type of wry comment that you can hear the irony in your mind, but your recipient reads it on the screen and doesn't understand that you're trying to make a joke, If we fall back on the basic principles of communication, we tend to do better online.
And over time, our kids will learn how to do this better than we do, the same way that we learned how to use telephones better than our great-great grandparents did. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Well, let me change gears for a minute and talk about meeting someone for the first time,
whether that's a co-worker or a date. I mean, what's the best way to build rapport and connection right out of the gate? There's a lot of great research on this. I'll tell you a little bit about some work I had done, one of my very first papers on conversations, which is studying the kinds of questions you might ask somebody when you get to know them. Very often, we started thinking about questions because I think very often the strategy we take
when we're trying to meet somebody is to impress them, to give them a lot of interesting statements about ourselves or about the most recent news or the context around us. But very often when people have on their mind when they're meeting you is not just, is this person interesting, but are they interested in me? Right. Are they demonstrating that they care about what I'm saying, that they want to hear more? And so we started looking at the questions people ask when they first meet each other. This is both some sort of friendly settings, but we even actually looked at a data set of speed dates that was collected by some researchers at Stanford.
very high stakes first impression setting. And what we saw is that even though people ask a lot of questions, there's only some types of questions that really help build rapport in those initial interactions. And specifically, those are follow-up questions. So questions that appreciate what a person said and then dig deeper to help them build more. It's nice because it demonstrates listening, right?
So by asking a follow-up question, I'm asking a question that I only could have asked if I had been listening to what you just said, right? So it's proof, right? I can sit here and nod and make eye contact and give you little back channels while I'm waiting for my turn to say something, right? No, that's not real proof of grounded listening, but if I can ask questions that show that I'm following the story, that I'm dying to know what's coming next,
that that's the really great way to get people to like you more because they feel like you're interested in that. It's also nice because it keeps the conversation going. It just gives them one more thing to see. say on a topic that they've already sort of revealed a preference for talking about. And so I try and get in the habit of asking as many follow-up questions as I can. And I think you'd be surprised when you meet somebody, especially if they're a little nervous, if they're worried about how they're coming across.
You know, you could ask a lot of follow-up questions before they ask you a question in return. And so you'll learn a lot, but then also they'll also get the side benefit of having them like you more. It's worth mentioning because I think Mike's points are so smart and so great that like if you just ask follow up questions, people love to answer questions about themselves, right? Nobody ever says, you know, you know, you're just too interested in me. But one of the things that I've carried into sort of new encounters is some work from Nicholas Epley. There's actually a whole chapter about Nick Eppley in my book. And Mike obviously worked with him for a long time. And one of the things, one of the things Nick said to me was he said,
You know, you could ask a lot of follow-up questions before they ask you a question in return. And so you'll learn a lot, but then also they'll also get the side benefit of having them like you more. It's worth mentioning because I think Mike's points are so smart and so great that like if you just ask follow up questions, people love to answer questions about themselves, right? Nobody ever says, you know, you're just too interested in me. But one of the things that I've carried into sort of new encounters is some work from Nicholas Epley. There's actually a whole chapter about Nick Eppley in my book. And Mike obviously worked with him for a long time. And one of the things, one of the things Nick said to me was he said,
his goal is to ask a deep question as quickly as possible. And a deep question is basically something that asks someone else to talk about their values or their beliefs or their experiences, to expose a little bit of who they are. And when Nick told me this, I was like, deep question, that sounds really hard to do like, you know, off the bat. That sounds very intimate. And Nick was like, no, no, it's actually just about like, you know, if you ask someone like, where do you work? And your next question is, do you love that job? Or did you always want to do that from when you were a kid? If instead of asking someone where they live, you say, you know, what's the best thing about your neighborhood? Or instead of asking them where
they went to high school, what did you learn most in high school? Those are deep questions. They don't seem overly intimate or personal, but they're inviting the other person to talk about their experiences or their values or their beliefs. And in doing so, they become a little bit vulnerable. They expose themselves. And if you reciprocate that vulnerability, if you show them that you are listening and you ask follow-up questions, as Mike pointed out, if you share a little bit about yourself, it's almost impossible not to feel close to that person. So you're mentioning that certain kinds of questions that work better than others to draw people out and to build that rapport. I imagine that you're familiar with the work of Arthur Arons, who was on this podcast some time ago. And he developed a series of questions that were intended to basically help people fall in love and stay in love.
I mean, have you looked at those questions and why do they work the way that he says they work? Oh, yeah. Actually, that chapter about Nick Epley is also the story of the Fast Friends Protocol and the 36 questions. And Arthur and his wife, they developed that together. And what's really interesting is I talked to a bunch of the grad students who worked with them on developing that. And we think of these 36 questions as like being set. in stone, right? But the origin of those questions is actually like almost by happenstance. There was, what they would do, there was this game that was really popular in the 1980s among
like college students and stoners named the ungame. Some of you might be familiar with this. And it's basically a bunch of random questions. So they would take these questions and they would experiment with them in bringing the in the fast friends protocol. And they would go to bars and they would just dream up, dream up questions. And for anyone who's not a familiar, what the experiment was that the errands conducted was they would bring strangers together. They would give them a list of questions to ask each other one at a time and answer. And then people would leave. And these were strangers. And then seven weeks later, they would look to see if anyone who had participated in this had tracked down their partner to try and just have a beer with them. And they found that over 50% of
the people who had done these questions, and this is pre-internet, right? They had to, like, work hard to track down these folks. Over 50% of the people went and found their partner and sort of made, because they felt such a connection with them after asking and answering these questions. And it became known as a fast friend's protocol. I'm sure everyone listening has heard of this, has probably used it. But the reason it works, and Mike, I'd love to hear your thoughts on whether you think this is right. The reason why Arthur told me it works is because of this reciprocal vulnerability because I ask you a question that asks you to be a little bit vulnerable, you answer it, and then I respond by answering that same question myself.
And that escalating vulnerability, that reciprocation, it just makes us feel close to each other, even if we have nothing in common. We feel close. Yeah, the reciprocal self-disclosure is a really powerful part of that paradigm. I think a little bit of what Nick was talking about, too, in the sense that you sort of ease into the topics that are surprisingly deep. It's an interesting paradigm too, right? There's a lot of sort of quietly staring into each other at the eyes.
这种不断升级的脆弱感和互动，让我们感觉彼此很亲近，哪怕我们毫无共同点。我们就是觉得亲近。没错，相互自我披露是该范式中非常有力的一部分。我认为尼克刚才提到的一部分也很契合，意思是你会逐渐切入那些出人意料地深奥的话题。这也是一个很有趣的范式，对吧？大家会有一段时间静静地注视着彼此的眼睛。
And there's a bit of a structure that kind of gives you the permission to be vulnerable that might be a little trickier in a natural setting, right? Like it's a wonder why we don't feel as comfortable sharing our vulnerabilities with people without having an experimenter poking us in the shoulder with a conductor's wand. But I think we all have something to learn from that study for sure. And I think Mike raises a really good point here, which is the structure is really important. Because some of the questions are things like, when's the last time you cried in front of another person? Or there's some question about people's mothers, right, which is not an overwhelmingly positive question.
这种结构赋予了你展现脆弱的许可，而在自然环境中这可能要棘手一些，对吧？难怪如果没有实验人员像拿着指挥棒一样戳我们的肩膀，我们在与人分享脆弱时就不会那么自在。但我认为我们所有人肯定都能从那项研究中有所收获。而且我认为迈克在这里提出了一个非常好的观点，那就是结构真的很重要。因为有些问题比如：你上一次在另一个人面前哭是什么时候？或者有些关于别人母亲的问题，对吧，这可不是一个压倒性积极的问题。
And I think if you're on a first date at a bar and you turn to someone and you say, you know, tell me, when's the last time you cried in front of another person? Probably that person is not going to take you out on a second date or go on a second day with you, right? Like some of these questions, but it feels fine when we're in a laboratory. But I think the point there is that as Mike mentions, and I think that plays off of a lot of his research, is that we can kind of create structures within our conversations. Right? Sometimes announcing our goal at the beginning of a conversation.
我想如果你在酒吧进行第一次约会，你转过身对某人说，你知道的，告诉我，你上一次在别人面前哭是什么时候？可能这个人不会带你进行第二次约会，或者不会跟你约会第二次，对吧？这些问题有些就是这样，但在实验室里时感觉就挺好的。不过这里的重点正如迈克所提到的，并且这也呼应了他大量的研究，那就是我们可以在对话中建立结构。对吧？有时在对话开始时宣布我们的目标。
is creating a structure or just saying like, you know, I wanted to get together with for drinks with you because I just wanted to get to know you better. Like tell me about who you are. Oftentimes what we're doing is we're creating structures that make certain kind of statements easier to accomplish, a question. And then a follow-up question is often a structuring mechanism. And the more that we sort of think about that or at least lean into it because it's an instinct for almost all of us, the more I think we make it easier for ourselves and others to respond. Related to that, though, let me ask you if you are about to embark on a difficult conversation and you let somebody know, I'm talking to you, I need to talk to you right now because I'm really angry. Does that set everything off on a bad path? Because now the other person gets defensive. So what should you do as the angry person? What should you do as the person who is maybe the recipient of?
就是在创造结构，或者只是说，你知道的，我想和你一起喝一杯，因为我想更好地了解你。比如，跟我讲讲你是谁。通常我们在做的事情，是在创造让某些陈述更容易完成的结构，比如一个问题。然后后续的问题往往也是一种建构机制。我们对这一点思考得越多，或者至少越倾向于这样做——因为这几乎是我们所有人的本能，我认为我们就越能让自己和他人更容易做出回应。不过与此相关的是，让我问你，如果你正准备开启一场艰难的对话，并且你让某人知道，我正在跟你谈，我现在必须跟你谈，因为我真的很生气。这会不会让一切都朝着糟糕的方向发展？因为现在对方开始有防御心理了。那么作为生气的人，你该怎么做？作为可能是……接收方的人，你又该怎么做？
the anger to keep it from devolving into just a mess. I'm trying to think if it's a harder conversation if one person is angry or if both people are angry. They both pose their own difficulties. I don't know that talking at the peak of your anger is always the best idea. But certainly there's a lot of difficult conversations we have that are a role around some kind of disagreement, right? Whether it's a different disagreement about beliefs or values or preferences, we're constantly, engaging with people we disagree with, right? In any group of folks, right, whether we're at work, whether we're managing a household or getting along with our neighbors, right? We're sort of
将愤怒控制住，不让它演变成一团糟。我在想要是一个人生气还是两个人同时生气，哪种对话更难。它们各有各的难处。我不知道在愤怒的巅峰时期进行交谈是不是总是个好主意。但可以肯定的是，我们经历的很多艰难对话都围绕着某种分歧，对吧？无论是对信念、价值观还是偏好的分歧，我们都在不断地与我们意见不合的人打交道，对吧？在任何群体中，无论是在工作中、管理家庭还是与邻居相处，对吧？我们都与这样的人紧密相连
intimately tied with folks who, it was impossible for us to agree with them 100% of the time. So we need to be able to build trust in spite of that disagreement. And I think a tricky thing in a lot of these situations is I think it comes back to goals. So often when we talk to people we disagree with. We're so focused on persuasion, right? Like, this person is wrong. They have a bad view of the world. So I just need to correct their view of the world, and then everything will be good again. But, like, you know, the hit rate on persuasion attempts these days is vanishingly small, right? If anything, the two people end up further away than they started, right? But the thing is, if you disagree with somebody about something and you talked about it and you haven't come to a resolution,
我们不可能做到100%与他们意见一致。因此，我们需要能够在这种分歧下建立信任。我认为在许多这类情况下，棘手的事情往往还是归结于目标。通常当我们与意见不合的人交谈时。我们太专注于说服了，对吧？比如，这个人错了。他们对世界的看法有问题。所以我只需要纠正他们对世界的看法，然后一切就又都好了。但是，你知道的，如今说服尝试的成功率低得惊人，对吧？如果说有什么不同的话，那就是两个人最终的分歧比开始时更大了，对吧？但问题是，如果你在某事上与某人意见不合，谈过后又没有达成共识，
in our negotiations class, we teach that means one of three things, right? Either you're wrong or the other person is wrong or both of you are wrong. And so there's a very different set of conversational skills that come into play when we disagree with people, right? If we focus on trust building and understanding, right, that's something that both people can achieve together, right? Even if I don't convince you that your opinion on, you know, Middle East politics or climate change or, you know, where we should go on vacation next
在我们的谈判课上，我们教导说这意味三件事之一，对吧？要么你错了，要么对方错了，或者你们两个都错了。因此，当我们与他人意见不一致时，会用到一套完全不同的对话技巧，对吧？如果我们专注于建立信任和理解，对吧，那是双方可以共同实现的目标，对吧？即使我没能说服你接受你对中东政治、气候变化或我们下次应该去哪里度假的意见。
holiday. Even if I can't win you over, I can still give you the gift of listening to what you have to say. I can express some intellectual humility myself by hedging statements by using tools to identify subjective language, right? So I believe this. I think that, you know, I understand where you're coming from. I can seek points of agreement, right?
假期，即使我不能赢得你的认同，我仍然可以给予你倾听你所说之话的礼物。我自己也可以表现出一些理性的谦逊，通过限定语句、使用工具来识别主观语言，对吧？所以我相信这一点。我认为，你知道的，我理解你的立场。我可以寻找共识，对吧？
rather than focusing on the narrow things where we disagree. So there's a lot of errors of omission that we make when we disagree with people, right? Things we should say more of. And there's also errors of commission, right? We contradict people too much. We minimize their beliefs by using words like just and only. We try and explain things to them as if, you know, we're a teacher talking to a student rather than two people of equal status trying to manage a disagreement between one another.
而不是专注于我们意见不合的狭隘方面。因此，我们在与他人意见不合时会犯很多遗漏错误，对吧？即我们应该多说的话。同时也有行动错误，对吧？我们反驳得太多了。我们用“仅仅”和“只是”这样的词来贬低他们的信念。我们试图向他们解释事情，就好像我们是一个老师在对学生说话，而不是两个地位平等、试图处理彼此分歧的人。
And so, you know, my colleagues and I have worked a lot on this sort of suite of conversational tools. We like to call conversational receptiveness, which is active engagement with people you disagree with. And what's interesting is that we show that this really builds trust in a lot of settings. So we've looked at this in, you know, telemedicine, we've looked at this in online classes. We've looked at discussions among Wikipedia editors and local government officials, all kinds of folks who are intimately engaged with folks they disagree with as part of a productive enterprise. And in all these cases, people who use these most more receptive language, which honestly doesn't sound much different from the sort of rule of thumb you kind of get from the literature
所以，你知道的，我的同事和我在这套对话工具上做了很多工作。我们喜欢称之为“对话接受度”，也就是与你意见不合的人进行积极互动。有趣的是，我们表明这确实在很多场景下建立起了信任。我们对此进行了研究，你知道的，比如远程医疗，我们研究了在线课程。我们研究了维基百科编辑和地方政府官员之间的讨论，各种作为生产性企业的一部分，与意见不合的人密切接触的人。在所有这些情况下，使用这种更具接受度语言的人——老实说，这听起来与你在60年代的伴侣咨询文献中获得的经验法则
on couples counseling in the 1960s, right? We build trust in these relationships the same way these couples do when they're having arguments. What's interesting is that the persuasion actually comes as a result of that trust. So rather than trading off persuasion against trust, right? We express a little humility and we think maybe we're giving in to the other side. In fact, it makes us more trustworthy and thus more persuasive. A colleague of mine has a great analogy of trying to enter a castle, like a medieval castle with a giant moat and a drawbridge.
差不多，对吧？我们在这些关系中建立信任的方式，和这些伴侣在争吵时建立信任的方式是一样的。有趣的是，说服其实是这种信任的结果。因此，我们没有在说服和信任之间进行权衡，对吧？我们表现出一点谦逊，我们以为自己是在向另一方妥协。事实上，这让我们更值得信赖，从而更有说服力。我的一个同事有一个很好的类比，就是试图进入一座城堡，就像一座带有巨大护城河和吊桥的中世纪城堡。
To get in, to see the king, you have to get them to lower the drawbridge, right? They don't lower the drawbridge. You're not getting in. So there's no point to begin with. And so in our research, we've shown that those extra tools, right, making really, really sure that the other person understands that you've listened to them before you launch into your statement about your side. I think that's a really good point. Yeah. And to build on that, you know, and the work that Mike has done with collaborators, including Allison Wood Brooks at HBS, you know, one of the things that comes across so strongly in that literature and other experiments is that,
为了进去见国王，你必须让他们放下吊桥，对吧？他们不放下吊桥。你就进不去。所以一开始就没有意义。因此在我们的研究中，我们已经证明了那些额外的工具，对吧，确保对方真正理解你在发表自己这边的观点之前已经听取了他们的意见。我认为这是一个非常好的观点。是的。在此基础上，你知道的，迈克与合作者（包括哈佛商学院的艾莉森·伍德·布鲁克斯）所做的工作，你知道的，在文献和其他实验中，有一个非常强烈的观点是，
Oftentimes we think about conversation as starting when I open my mouth. But in many ways, as we had discussed before, it's the work we do before we open our mouth. And equally importantly, the work we do after someone else has spoken to show them that we've listened to them. And one of my favorite ways of thinking about this is this technique called looping for understanding that many people listening who teach negotiations probably know, which is it's very, very simple. When you're in a conversation, particularly around conflict, and someone has said something, the best way to disarm the conversation, to prove to them that you are listening is you ask them a question about what they just said. You repeat back in your own words what you heard them say. And then you ask them if you got it right. And of course, we've all learned this when we were like in fourth grade, right?
通常我们认为对话是从我们开口说话时开始的。但在许多方面，正如我们之前讨论过的，它是我们在开口说话之前所做的工作。同样重要的是，我们在别人说完话之后所做的工作，向他们展示我们已经听取了他们的意见。我最喜欢思考这个问题的方法之一，就是这种被称为“循环理解”的技术，很多收听节目的、教授谈判的人可能都知道，它是非常非常简单的。当你在进行对话时，尤其是在围绕冲突的时候，当某人说了一些话，解除对话武装、向他们证明你在倾听的最好方法，就是向他们提出一个关于他们刚才所说的话的问题。用你自己的话重复你听到他们说的话。然后问他们你是否理解正确。当然，我们所有人都在四岁左右的时候就学过这个，对吧？
Like this is listening 101. And yet, and yet if you think about the last conversation all of us had when we were in conflict with someone, we probably didn't do a lot of looping for understanding. But if you're in that situation and someone comes up and they say, what I heard, like, let me ask you one thing about your opinion. What I heard you say is this. And they genuinely try and in their own words, restate what you're saying, restate what you're the argument you're trying to make. And then say, and before we proceed, can I just ask you, did I get that right? am I understanding you? At that point, it's pretty hard to see the other person as the enemy because they have shown
就像这是基础的倾听。然而，然而如果你想想我们所有人经历过的最后一次与某人发生冲突的对话，我们可能并没有做太多的循环理解。但如果你处于那种情况下，有人走过来，然后说，我听到的是，比如，让我问你一个关于你意见的问题。我听到你说的是这个。他们真诚地试图用他们自己的话，重述你所说的话，重述你试图提出的论点。然后说，在我们继续之前，我能问一下，我理解对了吗？我理解你的意思吗？在那个时候，很难再把对方视为敌人，因为他们已经向你展示了
you, they have proved to you that they want to understand you. That doesn't mean they agree with you. It doesn't mean they expect you to agree with them. But at least you know you're being heard. And once you have that trust, that conversational receptiveness, then it's much more likely that you're going to find places where you do agree with each other alongside the places where you don't. And that sounds like a tactic that people could employ if they're trying to become better conversationalists. Are there other tips that either of you might offer to our listeners who maybe recognize or maybe they don't recognize that they're bad conversationalists, but would still like to be good?
向你证明了他们想要理解你。这并不意味着他们同意你的观点。这并不意味着他们期望你同意他们的观点。但至少你知道自己被倾听了。一旦你有了这种信任，这种对话接受度，那么你更有可能在意见不一致的地方之外，找到彼此意见一致的地方。这听起来像是一个人们在试图成为更好的对话者时可以采用的策略。你们两位还有什么其他建议可以提供给我们的听众吗？他们可能意识到，也可能没有意识到自己是不擅长对话的人，但仍然希望变得擅长。
We talked a little bit about follow-up questions already, and I think that's a really generative and lasting approach. I will say that we have some other research on questions that might not go as well. There's a technique that, I don't know if any of you ever talk to my dad, you might know. We call it boomer asking. And the idea is that if you want to talk about a topic, you ask somebody else about it first so that you can then jump in and give your opinion. It has an intuitive appeal, right? Like I really, really want to tell this person about my great vacation that I went on last weekend.
我们刚才已经讨论了一点后续问题，我认为这是一种非常有创意且持久的方法。我要说的是，我们对其他可能效果不佳的问题也有一些研究。有一种技术，我不知道你们是否有人跟我的父亲聊过，你们可能会知道。我们称之为“老一辈式提问”。这个想法是，如果你想谈论一个话题，你先问别人关于这个话题的问题，这样你就可以顺势插话并发表你的意见。这有一种直观的吸引力，对吧？比如我真的、真的很想跟这个人讲讲我上周末去过的那次美妙的度假。
But I should probably include them and ask them about what their vacation was before I launched into my things, right? It seems like it's being responsive, but people catch on to this pretty quickly, right? They can see the insincerity if we haven't done a lot of work to actually listen to what they have to say. And so we actually find that when you want to talk about something great, it's better to just brag than to do the boomer ask and ask before bragging. It's also true for complaining too, right? So if you had a miserable day yesterday, it's probably just better to go in and talk about that and turn this into an emotional conversation rather than pretend you cared about what the other person did yesterday. So even complaining is better if it's explicit rather than channeled through the boomer ask. And so there's a lot of very tricky rules.
但我可能应该把他们包括进来，在开始讲我自己的事情之前，先问问他们的度假情况，对吧？这看起来像是做出了回应，但人们很快就会识破这一点，对吧？如果我们没有做很多工作去真正倾听他们要说的话，他们就能看出这种不真诚。因此，我们实际上发现，当你想要谈论一些美好的事情时，直接炫耀往往比使用“老一辈式提问”、在炫耀前先假装询问要好。抱怨也是如此，对吧？所以如果你昨天过得很悲惨，可能最好的做法就是直接去谈论这个，把这变成一场情感对话，而不是假装你关心别人昨天做了什么。因此，即使是抱怨，明确表达也比通过“老一辈式提问”来引导要好。所以这里有很多非常棘手的规则。
It's hard to have one particular piece of advice for all conversations, depending on what you want, depending on what the other person has in mind when you get to know them. There could be all kinds of tools. Charles, what comes in mind for you? Yeah. So my book Super Communicators is basically, it's, it's. It's a bunch of stories about people who interesting communication challenges, but then a lot of tips about how we actually, how we learn these skills, right? How we use them.
要针对所有对话提出一条特定的建议是很困难的，这取决于你的需求，也取决于你结识对方时对方的想法。会有各种各样的工具。查尔斯，你脑子里想到了什么？是的。所以我的书《超级沟通者》基本上是，它是一堆关于面临有趣沟通挑战的人的故事，但其中也包含了大量关于我们实际上如何学习这些技能、如何使用它们的技巧。
And some, in addition to what Mike mentioned, I think some other ones are, for instance, you know, Mike had mentioned that marriage counseling in the 1960s when there was really this revolution in the 60s and 70s. And one of the big ideas that came out of that was a lot of couples have trouble communicating with each other when they're trying to control. each other. And sometimes we don't understand that we're trying to control each other. We say things like, you know, if we're in a fight, like, I'm going to give this five minutes. Or if you say that one more time, I'm going to walk out of this room. And that's an attempt to control the other person. It tends to be toxic. Online, that often happens, right? Again, without intending to try and control each other, we signal that we want to control each other by saying, you know, you've analyzed this problem all wrong, or I'm not going to sit here and listen to that.
除了迈克提到的之外，我认为还有一些其他的例子，比如，你知道的，迈克曾提到过20世纪60年代的婚姻咨询，当时60年代和70年代确实发生了一场革命。其中一个核心理念是，许多夫妻在试图控制对方时，沟通往往会出现问题。有时我们并没有意识到自己在试图控制对方。我们会说这样的话，比方说，如果我们正在争吵，我会给这件事五分钟。或者如果你再那样说一次，我就离开这个房间。这是一种试图控制对方的行为。这往往是有毒的。在网络上，这种情况也经常发生，对吧？同样，在并非有意控制对方的情况下，我们会通过说“你对这个问题的分析完全错误”或“我不会坐在这里听这些”来发出我们想要控制对方的信号。
And I think that the more we think about giving up control in a conversation, letting it flow naturally, the better that conversation's likely going to be. Another tip that we can use, and we haven't really talked about non-linguistic communication, right? When we send messages with our bodies or with our sighs or our laughs, simply drawing our attention to those signals can really help a conversation. And in fact, there's a story in the book about in the 1980s, NASA had this one psychologist who was trying to figure out how to recruit more astronauts that had emotional intelligence. And the problem for him is that astronaut candidates, particularly elite astronaut candidates, they're really good at answering questions, right? They practice for every question. And they're really good at faking emotional intelligence because they know that they're supposed to exhibit it. And so this guy was trying to figure out, how do I like, how do I actually figure out who like can connect with other people and who can't?
我认为，我们在对话中越是想到要放弃控制，让它自然流淌，这段对话可能就会越好。我们可以使用的另一个技巧是——我们还没真正讨论过非语言沟通，对吧？当我们通过身体、叹息或笑声来传递信息时，仅仅将注意力吸引到这些信号上就能对对话大有帮助。事实上，书中有一个故事：在20世纪80年代，美国宇航局有一位心理学家试图弄清楚如何招募更多具有情商的宇航员。对他的难题在于，宇航员候选人，尤其是精英宇航员候选人，非常擅长回答问题，对吧？他们对每个问题都进行过练习。他们非常擅长伪装情商，因为他们知道自己理应表现出情商。所以这个人当时在想：我究竟该如何找出谁真正能与他人建立连接，而谁不能呢？
Because if we're sending them into space for six months at a time, that connecting ability is really important. And what he discovered by listening to old recordings of interviews is that if he paid attention to how the candidates laughed, it gave him a clue as to their emotional IQ. In particular, he started going into interviews and he would laugh very boisterously. and he would pay attention to whether the astronaut candidate would laugh back at the basic same energy and same mood level. And then he would laugh quietly and see how the astronaut responded to that. And it wasn't just laughter. He would also, he would mention that he had a sister who passed away, which was actually not true. He never had a sister.
因为如果我们要把他们送进太空一次待上六个月，这种连接能力就非常重要。他通过听以前的采访录音发现，如果他留意候选人是如何笑的，就能获得关于他们情商的线索。具体来说，他开始去参加面试时会笑得非常爽朗，并且会注意宇航员候选人是否会以基本上相同的精力和情绪水平笑回来。然后他会静静地笑，看看宇航员对此作何反应。不仅是笑。他还会提到他有一个去世的妹妹，而这其实并不是真的。他从来没有过妹妹。
But he would mention this in these interviews to see whether the candidate would try and comfort him and ask questions, whether they would share about a loss from their own life. It put differently, one of the things that he was doing was just training himself to pay attention to the non-linguistic clues that we give each other. And sometimes it's just as simple as that, just reminding ourselves like, pay attention to where the person's eyes are, pay attention to whether they seem to be laughing with me or not. These are just little things, little ways to remind ourselves, much like looping for understanding, right? they're just little mnemonics almost to remind us what we already know about communication and it can feel overwhelming
但他会在面试中提到这一点，以观察候选人是否会试图安慰他、询问他，或者是否会分享他们自己生活中的丧亲经历。换句话说，他所做的事情之一，就是训练自己去关注我们彼此发出的非语言线索。有时事情就是这么简单，只是提醒自己：注意观察对方的眼睛在哪里，注意观察他们是否似乎在和自己一起笑。这些都只是小事，是提醒我们的微小方式，就像为了理解而进行的回溯确认一样，对吧？它们几乎只是小助记符，用来提醒我们对沟通已经了解的知识，这可能会让人感到压力山大，
but it doesn't have to be they're all little things that if we just become more habitualized around doing them suddenly we start having much better conversations yeah Charles that's such a fascinating story and it hits on I think another really foundational principle of social interaction which is mimicry right
但大可不必如此。这些都是小事，如果我们对它们的做法养成习惯，我们突然就会发现彼此的对话变得好得多了。是的，查尔斯，这是一个非常迷人的故事，它触及了我认为社交互动的另一个非常基础的原则，那就是模仿，对吧？
A really good predictor of how someone's going to behave is how they're being treated. We're just hopelessly entrained to one another's behavior. And you see mimicry in so many different dimensions of human interaction. One person looks at something. We look at the same thing. We mimic each other in body posture. We mimic each other in gestures and facial expressions and motion and tone of voice. And certainly in the words we use too.
一个人会如何表现，一个很好的预测指标是别人是如何对待他们的。我们无可救药地受彼此行为的牵引。你在人类互动的许多不同维度上都能看到模仿。一个人看某样东西。我们也会看同一样东西。我们在身体姿势上模仿对方。我们在手势、面部表情、动作和语调上模仿对方。当然，在使用的词语上也是如此。
And that can be a really powerful tool, right? If we, that is unconscious cues in mimicry that signal that someone is on the same wavelength as us, that there's a bit of a shared reality, right? That we're enjoying the same things about the situation or, you know, miserating about the same things about the situation, right? That we're seeing things in the same way. Yeah. But I think this is a powerful tool. You know, I think in our work on disagreement, we're focusing a lot on the role of mimicry. And I think, you know, we're always, we're very often focused on how we can get other people to treat us with more.
这可能是一个非常强大的工具，对吧？如果我们利用模仿中的无意识线索，传达出某人和我们在同一频道上、存在某种共同的现实，对吧？即我们对这种情况有相同的感受，或者（你知道的）对这种情况有相同的抱怨，对吧？我们以相同的方式看待事物。是的。但我认为这是一个强大的工具。你知道，我认为在我们关于分歧的研究中，我们非常关注模仿的作用。并且我认为，你知道的，我们总是、非常经常地关注如何能让别人以更多的......来对待我们
respect, right? How we can encourage others to demonstrate receptiveness to us. And we found that one of the most powerful ways to encourage receptiveness in others is to be receptive yourself. Yeah. Right? That it improves other people's view of us and also all of our counterparts. And we can actually create these microcultures of respect and trust simply by making that choice ourselves. It's not sort of a one-to-one relationship, but the more we can express it ourselves, the more that people sort of unconsciously pick up on that tone and will reflect it back to us. And so even if it feels a little unnatural at first, once that cycle of respect starts revving up, it starts to feel real and hopefully can create a little more of a safe space
尊重，对吧？我们如何才能鼓励他人向我们表现出接受度？我们发现，鼓励他人接受度最强大的方法之一，就是自己首先要做到接受，对吧？它能改善别人对我们的看法以及我们所有对话者的看法。而且，仅仅通过我们自己做出这种选择，我们实际上就可以创造出尊重和信任的微文化。这并不是那种一比一的关系，但我们自己表达得越多，人们就会越下意识地捕捉到那种语气并将其反射给我们。因此，即使一开始感觉有点不自然，一旦这种尊重循环开始运转，它就会开始感觉真实，并有望创造出更多的安全感，
that maybe didn't feel possible when you get started. Yeah, I think that's a really good point. And it kind of raises this thing that we haven't talked about yet, but which, of course, underlies all of this, which is, the reason why mimicry is so important and so powerful is because in many ways mimicry is the point of communication, right? We haven't talked about neural entrainment and the work from Ari Hassan and Talia Wheatley looking at how our bodies become similar when we're in a, when we're in conversation with each other. Our eyes sometimes start dilating at the same rate. We start
而这种安全感在你刚开始时可能会觉得是不可能的。是的，我认为这是一个很好的观点。它引出了我们尚未讨论过的一点，但这当然是这一切的基础，那就是：模仿之所以如此重要、如此强大，在很多方面是因为模仿本身就是沟通的目的，对吧？我们还没有讨论阿里·哈桑（Ari Hassan）和塔利亚·惠特利（Talia Wheatley）关于神经同步以及当我们处于对话中时我们的身体如何变得相似的研究。我们的眼睛有时开始以相同的速率放大。我们开始
breathing in similar ways. But most importantly, our brains become more similar. And that's kind of the goal of communication, right? Is if I'm feeling a certain emotion and I threw my words can inspire you to feel that same emotion, then we have some level of understanding. We're communing with each other. And this mimicry is part of communication. It's in some ways the point of communication is for us to align our thoughts and our emotions and our beliefs, at least enough to understand what each other is saying and to transmit an idea or a feeling. And I think that's really, really powerful. And if we're focused on that, as a goal, then mimicry doesn't become sort of this slavish devotion to someone else's,
以类似的方式呼吸。但最重要的是，我们的大脑变得更加相似。这正是沟通的目标，对吧？如果我感受到某种情绪，并且我通过我的言语能够激发你去感受同样的情绪，那么我们就达到了一定程度的理解。我们在彼此心灵相通。这种模仿是沟通的一部分。在某些方面，沟通的目的就是为了让我们对齐思想、情感和信念，至少达到足以理解彼此所说的话并传递一个想法或一种感觉的程度。我认为这真的、真的很强大。如果我们把这当作一个目标，那么模仿就不会变成对别人的盲目崇拜、
to imitating someone else. It rather becomes the path to actually achieving communion. So I want to ask one question to wrap up here, and I'll ask you both. Has your work in this area changed the way that you talk with people and what lessons have you put into practice in your own life? And for you, Charles, did you become a better manager? I did. I did. And actually, I mean, I will. say it has revolutionized how I communicate. I mean, not just, not just with people at work, but also, you know, with my wife, with my kids. I mean, it's just taught me to think so much more deeply about how I'm communicating. And that can sound like a burden, right? Like it makes every
对模仿别人的盲从。它反而成为了真正实现心灵相通的途径。所以我想在结束时问一个问题，我要问你们两位。你们在这方面的工作是否改变了你们与人交谈的方式？你们在自己的生活中付诸实践了哪些经验？对你而言，查尔斯，你成为了一名更好的管理者吗？我是。我确实成为了。而且实际上，我的意思是，我会说这彻底改变了我的沟通方式。我的意思是，不仅是、不仅是与工作中的人，还有，你知道的，与我的妻子、我的孩子们。我的意思是，它只是教会了我更深刻地思考我的沟通方式。这听起来可能是一个负担，对吧？就好像它让每一个
conversation kind of this mental struggle. But actually what I found is that is that it makes communication much easier. Like I actually get to think less because because I know that I should ask a follow-up question or I know that I should I should reciprocate vulnerability when someone is vulnerable with me. You know, one of the first things that like often happens when I'm talking to my wife, and there's a shorthand we use for this that I think has become popular in schools, which is when we start talking to each other, we say, so do you want me to hear you? Do you want me to help you? Or do you want me to hug you? Right? And this is basically back to the beginning of our conversation. This is asking them what their goal is? Like, do you want me to solve? Is this a
对话都变成了一种心理挣扎。但实际上我发现的是，它让沟通变得容易得多。就像我实际上需要思考得更少了，因为我知道我应该问一个后续问题，或者我知道当别人对我敞开心扉时，我也应该回报以脆弱。你知道，当我跟我妻子交谈时，经常发生的第一件事就是，我们为此使用了一种简写，我认为这种简写在学校里已经变得很流行了，那就是当我们开始互相交谈时，我们会说：所以，你是希望我倾听你？你是希望我帮帮你？还是你希望我给你个拥抱？对吧？这基本上回到了我们对话的开始。这就是询问他们的目标是什么？比如，你是想让我解决？这是一个
practical conversation. You want me to help you solve it? Or do you want me just to hear your emotions, which is, you know, an emotional listening conversation? Or do you want me to hug you, to sort of a social conversation, to show you that we are still together? And simply asking that question has like, and I ask it all the time now. I drive people crazy with it. But like, it's this magical thing that all of a sudden people say like, oh, I want you to hear me. And then I know what my job is. And they know what their job is and things go so much more smoothly. Mike, what about you? That's a really good one.
实际的对话吗？你是想让我帮你解决它？还是你只是希望我倾听你的情绪，你知道的，这是一个倾听情绪的对话？或者你希望我给你个拥抱，这是一种社交对话，向你展示我们依然在一起？仅仅问出这个问题就已经——我现在一直都在问它。我把周围人都快逼疯了。但就像，这是一个神奇的事情，突然之间人们会说：哦，我想让你听听我倾听。然后我就知道我的工作是什么了，他们也知道他们的工作是什么，事情就会进行得顺利得多。迈克，你呢？这是一个非常好的问题。
I mean, I think it's so funny with science. I do think we're making a lot of progress, but sometimes the more you study a subject, the less you feel like you know about it. And for me, you know, I do a lot of follow-up questions. I do a lot of conversational receptiveness. I think my disagreements are more productive, although you'd have to ask my colleagues in Imperial College about that. You know, it's more the deep humility, right?
我的意思是，我觉得科学真的很搞笑。我确实认为我们取得了很大进展，但有时你对一个学科研究得越多，你就越觉得自己对它一无所知。对我而言，你知道的，我经常会问追问的问题。我有很多对话接受度。我认为我的分歧更具建设性，尽管你得去问问我在帝国理工学院的同事们才知道。你知道，这更像是深度的谦逊，对吧？
I plan to be surprised and I plan to learn from people because it's just so much more complicated than you can anticipate going forward. I always feel like there's so much more to learn than I could ever get out of one conversation. I've learned a lot with the two of you today, more than planned even. Yeah, me too. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today. I think it was a great conversation. Me too. Thanks for having me.
我计划着去迎接惊喜，我计划着向人们学习，因为事情比你预料的要复杂得多。我总觉得有太多东西要学，远超我从任何一次对话中能获得的。我今天从你们俩身上学到了很多，甚至超出了原计划。是的，我也是。好吧，我想感谢你们俩今天能来参加。我认为这是一次很棒的对话。我也是。谢谢你们邀请我。
Absolutely. It's been a pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's,
绝对的。这真是个荣幸。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）以前的节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件，邮箱是 speakingofpsychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪扬（Chris Condyenne）。感谢您的收听，美国心理学会。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。在拉尔夫斯（Ralph's）享受更多省钱方式，
like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years, Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. C-Sight for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
比如每个过道都有的低价。当你下载拉尔夫斯应用程序时，你每周都可以通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多费用。此外，你还可以赚取积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达1美元。在拉尔夫斯，每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，凭借优惠和奖励，每天省大钱总是轻而易举。拉尔夫斯，南加州150多年来的选择。省钱金额可能因州而异。适用燃油限制。请参阅网站了解详情。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。